bank robbery suspect is dead after an
officer-involved shooting in the
northwest valley this happened north of
cheyenne and tanea joe mohler there live
with what we know so far joe
that suspect died at the hospital after
being transported from the scene here
where this all ended here's a live look
at the investigation still happening at
this hour this is just north of cheyenne
antonia this is where the shooting
happened but there's also another
investigation where a bank robbery
happened as well
this is footage shot by a viewer the
suspect's car drives right by followed
by police around 11 30 metro got a call
of the bank robbery in progress in the
northwest valley they followed the
suspect believed to be involved to this
intersection the suspect stopped outside
of an apartment complex pulled out a gun
and that is when officers fired there
was a bank robbery and we are an
investment we are we do have units there
investigating it
and
it is connected to this particular event
metro did not say where the bank was
they did say there could be multiple
robberies that took place
metro will release more details in the
coming days this marks the 10th
officer-involved shooting this year
now back out here live you're taking a
look at the target parking lot which is
at tanea and cheyenne that was closed
for much of the day after
12 on and they just reopened this a
short time ago so that is open but the
investigation here on tanea north of
cheyenne does continue and will continue
for at least a few more hours so keep
that in mind if you are out here but
again one person is dead after this
officer-involved shooting reporting live
joe mohler live local now